hi and welcome to episode number 16 of
the weekly Google club up from podcast I
am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark hey Mark money I'll know
Mark mendel yes yes that's my name hi
going I'm good how are you doing pretty
good happy to be back to work on a
Monday morning oh yeah yeah but actually
very excited about the episode today
we're gonna have a lot of coover
Nettie's cooper Nettie's and more Coburn
at ease and a little bit of cooper
Nettie's yep and we actually have one of
the Cooper Nettie's people that
everybody associated suku Burnett is
really Cassie Hightower yes very
exciting yeah he's actually one of our
teammates yep in the developer advocacy
group for Google cloud platform yep and
he's gonna be talking about Cooper
Nettie's and especially about Cooper
night is one that to those versions are
gonna be discussing what is it where is
coming and it has some super cool
features that I get really excited about
yep I know I we normally what we do is
nobody we record the intro afterwards so
we've just done the interview and at
some point mark actually was basically
jumping of happiness so yeah it's gonna
be a very good interview yeah and after
that we're also going to be talking
about Cooper Nettie's yeah actually not
only Cooper nighties but maybe you can
explain a bit yeah so we had a person
who sent us a message I'm reddit talking
about having an app on app engine and
possibly my grading it to communities
and Google container engine and sort of
some pros and cons there so that all
discussion about that so we'll discuss
that at the end but before that we have
the cool thing of the week yes we do and
the cool thing of the week is something
that you're going to be explaining
because you're very involved with this
project but apparently we have a slack
channel we have slack community yes for
Google cloud platform yes we do so it's
a little bit about it excellent so yeah
I was quite involved in getting this set
up with a few other of our teammates
Cindy ray and Julia so if you're not
familiar with slack slack is a very
popular chat
work application it has all the usual
chat features of channels and rooms and
direct messaging and stuff but it's
become it's become very very popular mm
what we also noticed was that a lot of
open source projects and language
communities we're already sitting up
sort of slack teams for people to
participate in I know you're on the go
for his one yeah I myself is also there
I mean to slack communities go first and
go clap often I'm in 80 but yeah we
wanted a place for sort of a chat place
for people who use Google cloud platform
to use it and everyone was on slack it's
a low barrier to entry it's a really
nice platform looks very pretty too so
we created a google cloud platform slack
community so yeah if you're interested
in joining its bit ly / gcp deck lincoln
show notes exactly please definitely
come on down we've got obviously like
with a general chat room and we've got
you know product-specific chat rooms
it's a it's a mix of people right so
it's a community platform its public who
knows we have some Googlers but we have
a lot of like Google developer experts
in there as well and just general users
and it really is just like a place for
community um to get together to help
each other and really sort of get to
know each other as well yeah i've been
i've been part of the of the community
for quite a while now yeah and i really
like it because it's one of the most
welcoming communities I've seen a very
long time like people really asked like
beginner questions like hey I want to
understand how the datastore works and
people are really nice like they point
you to the documentation they will ask
they will answer any questions you have
so it's really really cool yeah and
there's also one of the channels we have
that are part of the community which I
take very personally and I like very
personally which is the podcast channel
yes we have a podcast channel there so
if you want to talk to France s can I
directly that's very true that's a very
good way of doing it other than our many
other ways of doing it yes maybe we'll
say at the end maybe not who knows um
yeah so if you want to join again go to
the show notes and we're gonna have a
link its speed Dudley / cece p dash
slack
definitely yeah I'd love to see there
yep and I guess that now it's time to
welcome our team mate Kelsey let's do it
today I am very pleased to announce we
have yet another special guest the
podcast I'm very pleased to announce
that we have Kelsey Hightower joining us
to talk to us about Gubru needs today
how you doing today Kelsey I'm going
fantastic any day is a good day I get to
talk about Coover daddy's excellent
excellent before we get stuck into
communities though let's have a little
bit of a conversation about you I'm sure
there are very few people who know who
you are who don't know who you marry say
that was that was a terrible fight I'm
sure there are very few people who don't
know who you are but do you want to want
to give us a little background on you
and who you are and what you do here at
Google yes I'm Kelsey Hightower's you
guys mentioned and I'm a very pragmatic
technologist I like things that work
less about the buzz and more about the
practicality of doing things so my
background is mainly as a cyst that min
maybe the last six years I kind of made
the transition to being a developer I
manage development teams management
managed Ops teams and part of my career
has grown into doing a lot of public
speaking and advocating for things that
work which has me now here at Google
pretty much doing the best of what I do
around Google cloud platform and related
technologies such as cover Nettie's
great yeah I remember first time I saw
you that was I think it was two years
ago i'd go for come ah yes that was the
most epic talk of my life you know
you're trying to do a go talk in front
of the go team and they're looking at
all your slides for centex errors that
is that's not the funnest thing in the
world yeah that was an amazing talk
though really really fun times excellent
excellent okay well why don't we sort of
dive right in we were talking about
Cabrini's we have had Brian Dorsey want
to talk about communities as well but
I'd love to get your take on it like
like what is kuba Nittis what does it
mean to you you know especially for
either people haven't listening to it or
just want sort of an alternate
perspective yeah well I when I look at
Cooper nazar when it first came out the
way I viewed Cooper name
this was more of a collection of ideas
that have been brewing from various
angles in the industry in general so
outside of Google the perspective was
everyone should be doing some form of
automation right whether it's puppet
chef rentable and a lot of those tools
got a lot of people very far I would
claim that the abstractions were wrong
you know we were basically wrapping you
know automation tools around low-level
things that were never designed to work
together like SSH and package managers
you can script those things but there
were just so many abstractions we were
dealing with and then when you see look
at Cooper Nettie's it looks like over
time some of the best practices that
people have been doing on the outside
world of course mixed with a lot of
things that Google has been doing
internally really just streamlines all
that stuff so if you look at it
cabernets to me just looks like a
checkpoint and where we are with
automation today right it's becoming the
I think will become the new baseline for
how people do things going forward and I
think it's going to be a new set of
abstraction so I don't see cover natives
of the end game I kind of see it as the
next level that people will be
automating against a new set of
primitives new set of abstractions cool
all right so let's let's maybe even take
it to a higher level if i'm i'm a new
user I've never heard of Cooper nidhi's
I don't know what it is I don't know
what it does how would you how would you
give me the 30,000 foot view of of what
that looks like I think when you talk
about Kerber neighs you start with the
application right so if config
management another tool you start with
the server and you kind of build it up
from there I think with Cooper daddy's
we assume that curb Renee's is installed
and that you have a set of API for
deploying your app so once you focus on
your app then we start to push in
various like hey how do you package that
at the abstraction we use this container
so you're going to wrap your app in a
container what you have in a container
then just going to express how you need
it to run how many copies do it doesn't
need to do you know what zones does it
need to run in and some basic high level
networking things how do people hit your
application that's the goal of cabernet
start with the app and with the app
awesome so you seem to be involved with
the communities project for quite a
while now I from from my history from
seeing you speak it seems like you've
been doing it forever how did you get
involved with group entities what's the
what's the history that
the history of Cooper neighs is pretty
interesting actually so at the time I
was working at core OS and at core OS we
were building what we like to describe
as Google's infrastructure for everyone
else and that's a tall order just
because no one has Google infrastructure
is that for google but we did pretty
good job of like delivering the whole OS
that's focused on containers and as we
moved up the stack we built a tool
called fleet and fleet used to talk to
etsy d which FTD was a cone of another
internal global service and fleet was in
its infancy at the time i would say
you'll definitely very high level you
can get basic things done and then one
day we're all watching the dr cohn
webcast where Brendan unveils kuvan it
is basically to everyone and at that
point in time I just knew that was the
way going forward that things like
fleeting all the low-level kind of
docker scripty tools would be no match
for that way of doing things and I think
that night i downloaded kuber Nettie's
and no documentation and really figured
out how to get it deployed and wrote one
of the first probably outside of google
blog posts about Cooper Nettie's it was
a full tutorial you guys did a PR
release which you know the thing big
companies do and we did this nice little
single node cover Nettie's how to guide
and you guys got number two on Hacker
News we ended up at number one so we're
really nice we were really thought about
that moves kind of a ninja move from the
startups I'm curious about you mentioned
that hcv was also part of these Google
infrastructure for everyone else what
what project could it be internally
could you explain will be more about
what EDD really is for people that has
I've never heard about it yeah so FCD is
basically a key value pair storage
server and you know a lot of people were
kind of compared to read us but you know
I guess they were thinking about it the
wrong way ideally it's modeled after the
chubby paper so as an internal service
google uses that has stronger guarantees
on consistency so a lot of people do
question like hey why do i need such
strong consistency when most
applications don't really have that
requirement but SED provides essentially
two things if you really think about it
it's a place to store your
configurations so ideally configurations
would be a list of back-end
that a group of web servers need to know
about so ideally you want all those web
servers to agree on what the backend
should be right maybe they don't
necessarily have the same list at the
same time but they should be guaranteed
that if they all agree on a single point
in time that they should have the same
list of backends right so it's a
configuration store ideally for
application configs so etsy d is not
designed to store gigs and gigs of data
so i think early on people were storing
image blobs and that CD and they do yeah
they really yeah yeah they really love
the high-availability features of STD
which is rooted in a consensus algorithm
called raft so wrapped is really nice
because it automates the membership
leader election and fell over so this is
very nice when you start to think in
terms of data stores where it's really
painful to set up a cluster of databases
and then handle adding and removing
nodes things like a TD that rely on raft
pretty much automate most of that
process for you so of course everyone
wants to use it for everything vertical
and I don't know I might be wrong but is
koo burnett is based on SED is it using
it somewhere yeah so that was one nice
thing about when that cabernets came out
it relied on a couple of kind of leading
projects so it picked docker for its
container at runtime instead of google
shipping their own and it also leverage
FTD so all of those principles we just
talked about or perfect fit for running
a cluster manager like covered Nettie's
and it really gave people that feel that
they were getting something really close
to what we have internally Borgore and
chubby that combination just goes
together and now we have an open source
combination as well that is very cool so
you mentioned that yeah so good Burnett
is when he was created it was built on
top of a TV and docker but you were
working at Cairo is right and Cora has
also had this different format for
containers rocket yes actually Cooper
neighs came out before rocket was
released actually so when the cover
Nettie's came out you know was all built
around doctor and I would say at that
time you know I think a lot of people
were rallying behind doctor and it
definitely fit the bill
at core OS the drive for alternative
container format probably started the
what we now call the container wars but
there's this idea that you know the
container runtime should be super small
and focused and that container runtime
that was built at Carlos it's definitely
called rocket and rocket was designed to
pretty much work well with something
like uber daddy's right so rocket
doesn't have a centralized Damon we rely
on something like Cooper Nettie's for
that rocket also has a concept of pods
so this was a new notion introduced by
Cooper Nettie's that in order to compose
applications in the way that would be
easy to schedule and manage you would
need to be able to put more than one
container in a container that you could
schedule atomically so the idea is that
many applications i don't know sometimes
i'll end up working with a node.js app
and it needs something like engine nexus
it on top so pause give you kind of an
easy way of putting those two things
together and shipping them around really
gives people like that virtual machine
feel right you can push these things out
the same way you've been managing bm's
in your infrastructure today very cool
so yeah that give us a little bit of an
idea of how good were natives came to be
and what it really is but if I will if
imagine that I'm creating my startup and
I'm considering using Cooper Nettie's or
maybe all the tools why could be the
other tools that I might consider and
why should i use Coburn at ease and not
something else yeah this comes up quite
a bit right so I think when I usually
talk about Kerber natives it's like if
you think peruke was a good idea but
it's a little too restrictive and you
want to walk one step back so maybe you
can have a little bit more choice on
where you host it what type of things
you can run so if i look at Kerber
natives I'd say it's maybe one or two
steps below a pass so if you're a
startup looking to deploy your
application and you really are not
trying to build out a full ops team or
deal with a ton of infrastructure then
cabernets kind of gives you the right
set of api to say hey look i don't mind
packaging my things in containers but i
do want some flexibility over the
runtime so things like Heroku would
probably have some restrictions on what
runtimes you can run or what libraries
you could use right and we have the kind
of the same set of restrictions on the
side of App Engine right so the idea
there is that you know in order for us
to do all the
magic behind the scenes we do have a hat
we have to introduce some constraints
and those are shared multi-tenant
platforms so with cover Nettie since you
kind of run that on your own cluster of
machines kind of gives you the
flexibility to run it where you want
even though our competitors do have the
ability to run Cooper Nettie's it's a
design goal of Cooper Nettie's that you
can run it on your laptop your data
center or inside the cloud and if your
startup that may be interesting to you
right maybe you get started on a mac
mini in the office and decide to push it
to the cloud later and you have the
flexibility of packaging anything you
want so if you want to you know have a
bunch of security vulnerabilities
running on an old version of Java you
totally can do that in cover days we do
not force you down any path but uh yeah
I think people like that is the
flexibility that makes sense that makes
it is now is this is a leading question
but as someone who has spent much of the
last little while setting up clusters of
communities where is your favorite place
to get started with community so getting
it getting it set up I honestly at this
point I just tell people we need to just
click the GK button you know it sounds
like we're copying out here but you know
what I what I'm starting to understand
is that a lot of people love this idea
that coo bearnaise is this open source
project it is a rare case that a cloud
provider provides the same thing that
they run in charge customers for as a
free thing that they can download and
run their own gear right that's pretty
amazing so of course the first thing
people want to do is deployed themselves
and it's like well you know you have to
make a lot of decisions here right so
I'm not I don't talk too bad about
OpenStack but I could never get
OpenStack deployed so there were a lot
of moving pieces and OpenStack I think
corona is far easier to deploy then
OpenStack is mainly because we don't
have to deal with the physical world
underneath we assume we have a node
abstraction in place but there's a lot
to managing a cluster and I think a lot
of people that are interested in Coober
Nettie's want to manage applications so
this is why I say hey look cut your
teeth on gke learn the KU béarnaise API
and this have that sit down discussion
where you talk about topology where you
want to run cabernets do you want to run
into your own gear maybe a different
cloud provider but i don't think the
right way to get started with Cooper
neighs in my opinion if you're
interested in deploying application
is to go through all the work of
deciding how you want to deploy covered
entities so with that said we do have
cube up so there is a script for though
that do want a single command you can
use it and by GK I just want to be clear
for those people who are listening
that's a Google container engine yeah
and we use gke for two reasons one is
the sea was already taken TG CES already
compute engine and then decay also
stands for cuva ladies there you go so
yeah I would I wanted to add it on the
on the fact that you mentioned that you
can run Cooper nineties basically
anywhere you want and for those that
have not seen it one of our teammates
rights and created this really cool demo
with collaborating with someone in Jay
focus where they were running Cooper
Nettie's in a data center made of five
raspberry PI's on the table so that was
pretty cool yeah I mean I think that's
the biggest selling point for people
recover neighs that we finally have I
would probably say like the first cloud
OS because when I think about what
Cooper neighs does is more than just the
point applications right it provides
that nice abstraction over storage it
normalizes the cloud providers where you
don't have to deal with the individual
API calls what you get cover neighs up
and running you can almost target that
going forward that makes a lot of sense
I like that a lot it sort of then
becomes it levels the playing field to a
degree it's like who who's going to give
the best communities experience and
really then adjust the consumer wins out
of everyone but you know what since
we're on this podcast I think the most
thing that I think when people start to
look at kerber Nettie's I hope that they
see this as an opportunity to pay back
some of that technical debt you know I
mean to a lot of people that have issues
with adopting a platform like urban
areas like having an automated scheduler
that can move your application around at
any point in day by far as the biggest
barrier but it's only a barrier because
a lot of people have built up so much
technical debt on assuming that
applications only get deployed to
specific machines if the Machine goes
down people run around wearing pagers
and all of this and I think this is
probably the right time to sit down and
say look there
limit their small amounts of things we
could do to make our apps fit really
well on this world and I think a lot of
people use the word legacy as a barrier
to say hey we can't use this new stuff
because we have these legacy apps and
the truth is I think it's really simple
for people to make small changes either
to log the standard out you know retry
database connections before segfault
team things like that you can easily do
in these applications regardless of when
you wrote them that will make them a
much better fit for running in something
like Cooper Nettie's very cool before we
move to the next topic I wanted to learn
a little bit more about how this login
work like you mentioned that rather than
psych folding or just blogging or like
just failing your program should log
something is there some specific library
that people should use or just like
logging to send our error and just hope
for the best yeah Sokka bernetti is like
you know I guess you know Heroku price
set the stage for this as you know part
of the team at haruka wrote the 12
factor manifesto and it was this idea
that when you're dealing with the more
capable platform you don't necessarily
need to write to your own log files
mainly because the files you know
there's no guarantee that you even have
access to write to the disk and it also
reduces where we can run containers on
how we restrict them so the idea with
logging is that we follow some of the
things that you see in the 12 factor
manifesto think it's like 12 factor net
it talks about logging and the simplest
thing you can do and the best practice
is just simply log to standard out so
pretty much no special libraries needed
no syslog libraries you don't need to
really deal with the integrating with
like elastic search or any of those
things all you really need to do is log
to standard out and allow the platform
to aggregate those logs and send them to
a central source or provide this the
structuring required to query them later
so that's the nice thing about this new
movement around 12 factor style
applications that it out yeah that is
very cool so I think that we should talk
a little bit about one of the reasons
why we have you in the podcast today
which is not only because you're awesome
but also because the next version of
carbonate is
Renee's one the two it's going to be
released very soon so could you tell us
a little bit about it what is coming on
so I think Cooper Nettie's really
represents what happens when an open
source project gets popular right you
start to get a lot more contributors you
start to get people running into
production and the details that come out
of that is what one tattoo represents
right so there's been a lot of work on
improving the way we do deployments so
in Coober Nettie's everything is modeled
with the object so if you want to have a
service you want to deploy a set of
containers they all have their own API
object that describes them so one of the
patterns that we saw a lot of people
really engaged in with cabernets was
things like roaming updates and this
idea of describing we know something
that can be scaled easily using what we
call a replication controller which was
a babysitter over a set of containers so
what we did with that particular pattern
is we introduced this deployment object
so the plum has become this first class
thing in coover nays 1 dot to that will
allow you to kind of describe your
update policy you're scaling
requirements all in a single object and
that single object will basically
abstract a lot of lower level things
from people and be much easier to work
with so Cooper Nettie's also introduces
the config map so a lot of things we saw
a lot of people doing in criminate one
day one and one dado was using what we
call secret so secrets was a way to
store configuration key values and
present them to the application at
runtime they were designing for secrets
but since that was the only mechanism to
do late binding of configuration and
applications we introduced this thing
called config map which was really
designed to allow the application to be
notified when there's changes so if you
use config match instead of secrets very
similar ap is you can store not only key
value pairs but you can dispose them as
environment variables or files on this
and also notify the actual machine that
the configuration has changed so those
are the kinds of two big things that I
like that's also that I haven't been
keeping us up-to-date with Cuban it
eases I should be and the fact that you
can do config maps to environment
variables was a huge pain point for me
so I'm super happy to hear that oh and
also the tooling so you know some of the
small things a lot of people don't talk
about is the tooling has improved
greatly so now you know I'll walk you
through what it took to create a secret
before used to have to base64 encode
some file into a key value but now you
can actually automate that on the
command line so you can run khoob CTL
create secrets name the secret and then
dash dash from file and it would do all
those things for you and store them as
the file name automatically and all you
have to do is reference that file name
when you reference the secrets in your
pod manifest so that should just cut
down just on a ton of work for for end
users nice I think you just so had I see
mark over I see mark over here smiling
big time and I think a lot of people
yeah well too because we all these a lot
of these features just straight up
removing removing friction yep that's
phenomenal yeah that is great i was a
little bit curious about how how is coo
benetti's managed meaning that these
these features that have been added are
like clearly something that the
community wanted or least mark want it
is it really community management what
do i do if i want something to be added
to the community to the to cooper
Nettie's do i file a bug yeah so the
nice thing about Cooper net is this
completely run on github so it's one of
the rare projects for the issues and the
code are all managed on github so we
basically follow you know the standard
workflow that most projects hosted on
github follow if you want something
changed you can open the issue and we're
not very strict on how much detail you
need to put in that issue you know
people on the kerber Nettie's community
will do a lot of work reproducing your
issue or you know given a response but
if you want to add a new feature you
start with an issue you know some of
them will either search the other issues
that are open to see if that features is
already slated to go we do keep a public
road map with milestones so you know
we're already actively planning 13 I
think of some few issues have already
been tagged and then we collaborate with
the user so if you if you submitted
something we do solicit help so we do
welcome code contributions there are
people help review your code there's
also lots of collaboration from
companies like Huawei and red hat
core OS you know those three companies
are doing a lot with their users to
satisfy those requests so it's very much
a collaborative project you pop over to
github and you know we make things
happen awesome that sounds sounds pretty
egalitarian so we're slowly running out
of time here a little bit to a couple of
final questions for you I want to ask
what's the coolest thing you've seen
somebody build on communities the
coolest thing I've seen someone built on
kerber Nettie's what was probably about
a year ago I was given a Korean aids
workshop in Portland and there's a
company locally in town jive software
and they showed up and they're like
let's let us show you our our demo and
may show me this dashboard and that was
pretty clean I mean they were using
every single cover Nettie's feature at
the time including things like secret so
what what you could do on their platform
was you could kick off a three-tier
application and when you deployed the
database it would automatically generate
its own secret and stored in coover
Nettie's and the web applications would
wait for that secret to show up and then
use that secret to connect to the
database so you know they basically
built their own kind of platform that
would automate the thing like creation
of data stores and passwords without a
human intervention I thought that was
really clever because you know they did
that with very little you know no
permission from the curb Renee's team
but the api's were just awesome enough
for them to pull it off so you know it
was a nice little web UI figured man I
wish that was an open source project so
that was pretty that was pretty cool it
does sound pretty cool awesome and as a
final question is there anything here
you want to mention that we haven't had
a chance to mention it I'm sure there's
a lot we could talk about but I think a
lot of people when it comes to kerber
Nettie's I want people to understand
that it's not a pass you know it's not a
platform as a service is very much a I
like to think of it as a scripting and
environment for developers and system
mins so if you want to have your perfect
platform I think cabernets is the
perfect place to start you should feel
comfortable building your own tools your
own deployment workflows your own
schedulers you know Cabernets are
designed to have multiple schedulers we
do ship on out of the box but you see a
lot of robust
Gorillaz coming from companies like
unova with their grid engine you know
you'll see a lot more coming down the
pipe but think of it as an open platform
for the modern age anything you can
think of automating consider doing that
on top of Korra days and our rich set of
AP is very cool well thank you so much
for being here with us today I learned a
lot I'm actually very excited about the
new version I've uska pernetti's a
little bit before Lee not enough to be
as excited as Mark was about comfy maps
but i'm sure that lots of people are
going to be excited and gonna be going
to appreciate your help so thank you so
much often thanks a lot kelsey so thank
you so much kelsey for an amazing
interview i learned personally a lot and
I know if we're excited about most of
the new features coming I totally can't
wait to play with config maps yeah
you're excited you everything about it
it's a pity way no recording this
because he was literally jumping so
anyway before we finish we have our
question of the week and I think that
you saw that question first so I'm gonna
let you explain sure so it's okay the
user on reddit is proven all thank you
so much for providing us this question
which is great thank you so much for
that I think it's actually quite
interesting so the question is hi I'm
very excited about Google container
engine and think it would suit some my
projects well one thing stopping us from
moving away from App Engine is that we
depend on the search or indexing API and
as far as I can see there's no external
API available for that yet I can't find
any information about it but are there
any plans open this service up to
applications residing outside of App
Engine like you did with cloud datastore
cool that's actually very very good
question yeah unfortunately one of the
things that the first part of the answer
is going to be we cannot really discuss
roadmaps now so we cannot save it is
coming or not but regardless of had that
API being available or not in the future
outside of a bench in something that
could be interesting to consider is well
why do you really need to move from my
pen
to compute engine I'm sorry to container
engine yep and do you really need to and
if you need to you know it's not a one
hundred percent things exactly to move
completely so what do you think so yeah
we were talking about this a bit before
and I think it's a completely valid
point it's not a you don't have to lift
and shift which seems to be a very
particular term that comes up a lot now
but you don't have to take your whole
thing there's a couple of ways you could
kind of go about this like for one
instance if you needed to you could just
expose the parts they use your search
api through App Engine is a rest
endpoint or something similar and access
it that way and then if you need to
access that from container engine for
example that it'd be pretty easy to do
it's all inside google's network super
fast yeah you could totally do that but
you know if you don't want to or don't
really need to move your application off
App Engine it's working well there's no
real reason to but you need say maybe
the power of the flexibility of
container engine for something specific
again you could just move that
particular part 2 container engine maybe
expose that as a rest endpoint or
something similar yeah leverage it that
way yeah it's all red green actually my
first reaction if I had something that
is already running a mean successful
yeah my pension and I had something that
for some reason like I want to use some
specific library like ffmpeg or
something that will not run on App
Engine yeah my first move could be
considered managed VMs yeah so if that's
the that's the reason what you think
about moving to Coober Nettie's probably
I could consider managed VMs first just
because it's going to be really easy for
you to migrate yep if you actually want
to move to go bananas for other reasons
like because it's really cool which it
is what I could consider is exactly what
Mark said what depends really on the
search and the search api search or
indexing API could be kept as a simple
recipe yet yeah so something really
simple that you have just running there
and it just being accessed as a external
service from your Cooper Nettie's
cluster so yeah I think that that's
actually a pretty good idea like yeah we
are not like container Engine and
compute Angie not
container engine compute engine App
Engine managed VM and so on we talked
about it during one of the first
episodes about how it's a continuum and
it's not only about the fact that you
have to be one of those ranges of how
much freedom or how much management you
want to have but it's also you can just
pick and choose for every single one of
the parts of your system and just spread
it all over that continuum yeah this is
about finding the right tool for the
right job and exactly beginner the thing
that's going to fit well for what you
need to do yeah so yeah and if we then
answer your question correctly because
you want it to know something
specifically I feel free to send another
message we love your messages we love
receiving messages and thank you to
everyone who listens and thank you to
everyone who participates we really do
appreciate it yep okay so I think that
it's time to go again so where are you
having where you going to be next week
next week oh my god I'm just started
freaking out so next week i will be at
GDC i'll be at the game developers
conference super excited about that if
you're going to be there will be doing a
developer day on day 1 i'll be hosting a
round table or two they are talking
about how you can use cloud sort of in a
discussion you can use cloud to
basically do interesting things of your
game how can it really change the game
you're building and also will be down at
the Google booth the Google cloud
platform section of the Google booth
I'll be there probably most of the time
so please definitely drop by would love
to talk to you about game development in
the cloud nice in yourself well yeah if
you're freaking out I don't know how to
describe how I feel like right now but I
will be in austin at the beginning of
the week until the end our side by
Southwest we're going to be running a
bunch of parties and events and lots of
fun lots of work also in the fiber space
so if you're around Austin come say hi
very happy to share our demos actually
we're gonna have a couple really cool
demos cloud spins gonna be there nice
will have been too yeah we can also have
a very cool demo that we have not spoken
about it yeah a nice day which is the
the but the
Jumba region but we should talk about we
should talk about that we should have
yeah we should have cast maybe an
interview him about the demo and after
that i will probably at GDC helping you
yep but also i'll be a drive gun which
is at the same time also trying to help
people and then on Saturday 19th we're
actually running a training session on
Google cloud platform so it's ep one
hundred and it's gonna be down in month
of you for the Silicon Valley iOS meet
up okay you win yeah you been so yeah
that's gonna be that yeah that's gonna
be some oh my god that's gonna be fun
yeah yeah did you want to sleep at I
think you know need it so yeah anyway
it's gonna be it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be found fun week next week so
again thank you Mark for being here and
helping with it at this episode thank
you to you as well and thank you to our
listeners still be so many of them
apparently yeah we started have a decent
amount of listeners but we're not
getting enough messages in my opinion so
please send us more messages what you
like what you don't like what do you
want to talk about they're either either
by email by reddit of a google+ or even
by the slack channel or Twitter or yeah
many many ways to contact us anyway
thank you so much thank you and talk to
you next week see you next week
you